but Happy Thanksgiving by the way thank
you very much I'm going to put my gut
Hider on love it thank very
much not going to laugh now it's now
it's out I love you right now um well
wait this is all this is we're it's like
we're related um so wait what today is
all about gratitude which I think is
perfect for you we were trying to find
because we love you on this show we've
had you on we're like what can we do
that's like different and special and
Thanksgiving was this week and you're
such a giving person but I think that
you're also always in a state of like
gratitude for everything as well which
is cool cuz you recognize all the
blessings yeah amen you're that same way
I am but you're like the next degree
we've talked about this me and my
friends yeah I everybody thought I was
like this and then they you were
introduced in their life and they're
like oh no you don't even count um but
what does this what does it mean to like
be grateful especially around
Thanksgiving like what do you do you do
go big for Thanksgiving your family yeah
well when you're married to well or the
greatest Cooks on the planet oh my God
don't brag about it well I won't I won't
we'll talk about how great of a singer
she is oh and we'll talk about that
that's probably five and six on our list
of top 10 things yeah do um but she uh I
think it's fun my thing is this and you
guys might feel the same way when it
comes to the future you know I think
it's what you're just grateful for is
just one more day right of getting to do
this so I think that's it just
truthfully if I could say what I'd love
to say is uh the day I take my last
breath on this planet I'd love for my
three girls to be around me and I love
for the queen to be around me but uh as
far as Miss Yearwood um I don't know you
know I've said this before I found her
in the past life I'll find her in the
next she just it's just I love well have
a great day
everybody she makes it fun you know yeah
know she makes it really fun CET lunch
GTH okay um so it is amazing though it's
such a beautiful love between the two of
you it is and you're tearing up and
you're making me tear up and my makeup
artist is going to kill me I'm not tear
enough so yeah you are yeah you are I
love
it
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home